à ce week-end le week-end prochain dans
le nord des Yvelines rurales avec le
festival tracteur blues qui se tient à
samedi à Breuil-Bois-Robert et dimanche
à Médan et c'est Chantal sipeletti qui
vient en parler avec nous en plateau
vous êtes donc la prison de Blues sur
Seine qui chapote cet événement on le
disait aussi tout à l'heure on
commençait à le dire au-delà d'être un
festival de musique c'est aussi une
valorisation plus globale du territoire
du territoire rural en l'occurrence
circuit court également l'environnement
qui est mise à l'honneur sur ce
festivals je veux juste rectifier si
vous me le permettez c'est vendredi 2
c'est vendredi et dimanche et samedi
et samedi 3 à mes dents vous avez bien
fait de faire la petite la petite
précision donc vendredi abribois Robert
samedi à mes dents pourquoi justement
proposer ce rendez-vous commençons à en
parler tout à l'heure il y a déjà blue
sur scène qui se déroule aux alentours
de novembre dans les Yvelines pourquoi
proposer ce rendez-vous à la fin du
printemps finalement ben parce que bon
on a blue sur scène effectivement au
mois de novembre mais vous savez dans
les petits villages des Yvelines
quelquefois et bien on ne se déplace pas
jusqu'à Nantes ou jusqu'à Conflans ou
jusqu'à Poissy donc jusqu'à Paris tout à
fait donc l'idée est venue de d'amener
le spectacle vivant au domicile des gens
donc depuis 8 ans puisque blues sur
scène va avoir 25 ans et le tracteur
blues va avoir 8 ans cette année c'est
la huitième édition nous allons dans des
petits villages du territoire de l'agpso
qui est notre notre territoire Grand
Paris
et nous allons dans des petits villages
c'est à dire des villages qui ont moins
de 2000 habitants qui n'ont pas de salle
de spectacle et qui donc n'ont pas de
spectacle vivant donc ça veut dire que
chaque année vous changez de village on
change de village chaque année tous les
jours
et le samedi et du côté de mesdans qu'on
soit passionné de blues ou un simple
initié ça s'adresse à tout le monde
c'est
un festival qui se veut rural bien sûr
mais aussi très familial
joyeux c'est gratuit l'entrée gratuite
donc tout le monde peut venir nous
arrivons le matin à 8h sur le sur le
lieu du festival avec un tracteur qui
tracte les normes scènes que nous avons
nous arrivons avec des artisans locaux
c'est pas et puis arrive les techniciens
qui sont les techniciens de Blue sur
scène du mois de novembre et tous les
bénévoles il nous installons tout ce
qu'il faut pour passer une très belle
soirée donc c'est pour ça tracteur c'est
parce que c'est c'est le tracteur qui va
amener la selle ça c'est une image
insolite à pas manqué
nous avons également une association qui
vient de Bréval avec de très vieux
tracteurs ils arrivent de Bréval à 10 à
l'heure donc je vous recommande de venir
les voir et vraiment c'est voilà c'est
ça se veut convivial alors six groupes
seront à l'affiche cette année que
faut-il retenir de la programmation
nous avons six groupes dont les toujours
les premiers de chaque soir sont des
groupes complètement locaux par exemple
le samedi soir nous aurons les élèves du
CRD de Mantes-la-Jolie le Conservatoire
rayonnement départemental qui seront là
nous avons également à breuil-bois
Robert
qui possède qui tient une chorale dans
son dans sa commune nous leur avons donc
proposé à devenir chanter puisque nous
sommes chez eux donc voilà et des
concerts à l'extérieur la la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'a priori la météo sera
bonne sans rendez-vous
la semaine sera ensoleillée
donc c'est quand même très agréable il y
aura de quoi se restaurer voilà c'est
quand même je trouve que dans les
moments un peu difficiles que nous
traversons les bruits de bottes pas très
loin un moment convivial où on peut se
poser je trouve que c'est quand même
très intéressant à notre époque et ça
c'est très important vous le disiez
c'est gratuit et ce qui est une place à
prendre à l'avance on peut venir
directement sur place chacun vient quand
tu veux il y aura également des jeux
pour les enfants des trucs pour se
restaurer enfin voilà et de la bonne
musique et de la bonne musique c'est le
principal bien sûr de cet événement donc
tracteur blues qui a lieu je donne cette
fois-ci les bonnes dates ce sera
vendredi 2 juin au Breuil à Breuil Bois
Robert sur la place du village
rendez-vous dès 19h sur cette place du
village et donc samedi dès 18h30 ce sera
rue Ronsard à Médan cette fois-ci et
vous allez tous les informations bien
sûr sur le site internet de blues sur
scène qui ont le rappelle chapeau de cet
événement